Kita semua butuh kemampuan untuk berkomunikasi informasi pribadi tanpa takut ada yang menyadap. Tapi merancang
sistem yang sempurna untuk ini tidaklah mudah. Dalam episode hari ini dari Qiskit in the Classroom, kita akan membahas bagaimana
sesuatu yang disebut quantum key distribution bisa
membantu. Selamat datang kembali di Qiskit in the Classroom. Dalam seri ini, kita akan membahas topik yang mungkin kamu temui dalam kursus universitas terkait
quantum computing. Setiap video dilengkapi modul interaktif yang ditautkan di deskripsi, jadi
pastikan kamu cek itu. Hari ini, kita akan masuk ke ranah kriptografi kuantum. Kriptografi adalah studi
tentang teknik komunikasi yang aman. Ini sangat penting untuk banyak bagian dari kehidupan kita. Setiap kali kamu menggunakan
kata sandi untuk masuk ke situs web, mengirim pembayaran digital, atau ketika pemerintah mengirimkan intelijen militer, semuanya dilakukan
melalui beberapa protokol kriptografi agar penyadap tidak bisa mempelajari rahasia kita. Tapi ada ketegangan di sini. Bagaimana
kita memastikan bahwa orang yang ingin kita ajak berkomunikasi bisa memahami pesan kita, tapi tidak ada orang lain?
Secara historis, kriptografer sudah menemukan banyak protokol berbeda untuk mencoba membuat pesan mereka seimmun
mungkin dari penyadap. Kadang-kadang dua pihak yang ingin berkomunikasi secara aman menyepakati beberapa
kode sebelumnya yang diharapkan sangat rumit sehingga penyadap tidak akan bisa memecahkannya. Tapi seperti yang
ditunjukkan oleh orang-orang seperti Alan Turing dan pemecah kode lainnya di masa perang, bahkan kode yang paling rumit pun bisa
dipecahkan. Idealnya, kita ingin mengirim pesan yang dienkripsi sedemikian rupa sehingga tidak ada pola sama sekali
dan tidak ada cara bagi penyadap untuk memahami tanpa juga memiliki kunci acak rahasia yang hanya diketahui pengirim dan
penerima. Tapi kemudian kita membuka diri pada kerentanan baru. Bagaimana kita bisa mengirimkan kunci ini dan memastikan bahwa
tidak ada yang mencegatnya? Pada tahun 1984, Charles Bennett dan Jill Brassard menemukan
metode untuk mengirim kunci dengan aman menggunakan bit kuantum, yang sekarang disebut BB84. Fitur utama dari bit kuantum
atau qubit ini yang memungkinkan protokol ini adalah mereka mematuhi prinsip ketidakpastian. Kamu tidak bisa mengukur
sistem kuantum tanpa mengganggunya. Hari ini, kita akan mulai dengan contoh kode kriptografi sederhana. Kemudian aku akan
menunjukkan bagaimana quantum key distribution dan prinsip ketidakpastian bisa memungkinkan kita menggunakan enkripsi yang hampir
tidak bisa dipecahkan. Aku akan memandu kamu melalui protokol BB84 secara detail dan akhirnya kita akan menjalankannya pada
komputer kuantum nyata. Pertama, mari kita mulai dengan permainan yang mungkin sudah pernah kamu lihat sebelumnya yang disebut kriptogram.
Kamu diberi urutan huruf yang tampak acak, tapi dengan menggunakan pengetahuanmu tentang pola dalam bahasa
Inggris, kamu bisa mengganti satu huruf dengan huruf lain untuk memahami pesan tersebut. Ini contohnya. Ini adalah
pesan rahasia dengan cipher substitusi sederhana. Jadi, semua R mewakili satu huruf, M mewakili
huruf lain, dan seterusnya. Kalau kamu ingin mencoba memecahkannya sendiri, pause video sekarang.
Ternyata pesan ini dienkripsi menggunakan cipher yang sangat sederhana yang disebut Caesar cipher di mana
alfabet hanya digeser sejumlah tertentu, dalam kasus ini 9. Jadi A menjadi J, B
menjadi K, C menjadi L dan seterusnya. Semakin panjang pesannya, semakin mudah untuk
melihat polanya. Jadi, dengan pesan sepanjang yang kita berikan, Caesar cipher atau cipher lain yang hanya
menggantikan satu huruf dalam alfabet dengan huruf lain cukup mudah dipecahkan. Cara yang lebih aman untuk mengkodekan pesan rahasia
adalah dengan yang disebut one-time pad. Dengan one-time pad, kamu bisa memiliki pergeseran yang berbeda untuk setiap huruf dalam
pesan. Kamu hanya perlu memberi tahu temanmu berapa pergeserannya pada masing-masing agar mereka bisa mendekode pesan tersebut.
Daftar pergeseran ini disebut kunci atau pad. Ini disebut one-time pad karena digunakan sekali lalu dibuang.
Kalau digunakan lebih dari itu, pola akan muncul yang bisa membuat enkripsi bisa dipecahkan. Dengan enkripsi
one-time pad, baik pesan terenkripsi maupun kunci secara individual hanyalah string omong kosong yang acak. Tapi
ketika kamu menggabungkannya, kamu melihat pesan rahasia muncul dari kebisingan.
Mari kita lakukan contoh singkat. Katakanlah aku sudah membuat dan mengirimkan kepada temanku one time pad ini yang biasanya ditulis dalam
biner. Dan kemudian aku ingin mengirim pesan "I love quantum". Kemudian aku akan mengkodekan pesannya
menggunakan one-time pad seperti ini. Pertama kita mengonversi huruf-huruf dalam pesan kita ke biner. Setiap huruf A sampai Z akan
sesuai dengan angka 1 sampai 26 yang ditulis dalam biner. Jadi A akan menjadi 0 0
0 1 B 0 0 1
0 C 0 0 1 1 dan seterusnya.
Dan kemudian spasi akan menjadi semua nol.
Kemudian inilah yang menjadi pesan. Kita mengkodekan pesan dengan melakukan XOR antara setiap bit dalam pesan dan
bit yang sesuai dalam one-time pad. Kalau kamu belum pernah melihat XOR sebelumnya, ini
singkatan dari exclusive or. XOR antara dua bit akan menjadi satu jika hanya satu
dari bit tersebut adalah satu dan nol jika keduanya nol atau keduanya satu. Jadi set pertama dari lima bit dalam pesan terenkripsi
menjadi 1 0
0 1 1. Aku akan menyisakan sisa XOR untuk kamu kerjakan sendiri. Tapi intinya adalah
pesan ini sekarang hanyalah string acak dari nol dan satu tanpa pola. Sama sekali tidak bisa dibaca oleh siapa pun yang
tidak memiliki one-time pad yang kita gunakan untuk mengenkripsi pesan. Jadi, apa yang sudah kita pelajari sejauh ini? Beberapa skema enkripsi
lebih baik dari yang lain, dan beberapa bisa disimpulkan oleh orang cerdas yang mencari pola dalam pesan
terenkripsi. Tapi kunci yang benar-benar acak yang menggeser setiap huruf dalam pesan rahasia sejumlah acak yang berbeda tidak bisa
disimpulkan karena tidak ada pola dalam pesan tersebut. Satu-satunya kerentanan dalam skema seperti ini adalah memastikan
bahwa kunci yang digunakan untuk mengenkripsi pesan tidak jatuh ke tangan yang salah. Di sinilah quantum key
distribution berperan. Dengan menggunakan qubit, Bennett dan Brassard menemukan cara bagi dua pihak untuk menyepakati kunci dan
cukup yakin bahwa pihak ketiga tidak diam-diam mendengarkan. Protokol BB84 ini agak rumit, tapi
kita akan membahasnya langkah demi langkah. Untuk penjelasan ini, mari kita hadirkan kembali teman lama kita, Alice dan
WEBVTT
Bob. Protokol dimulai dengan Alice menyiapkan sekumpulan qubit untuk dikirimkan ke Bob. qubit-qubit ini mengandung
informasi yang akan menjadi one-time pad atau kunci bersama mereka. Alice pertama-tama menghasilkan dua urutan acak dengan
panjang yang sama. Satu adalah urutan acak dari nol dan satu dan yang lain adalah urutan acak dari x dan z yang mewakili
basis di mana dia akan menyiapkan qubit-nya. Kemudian dia akan menyiapkan setiap qubit dalam state kuantum sesuai dengan
kombinasi basis dan nilai bit yang ditunjukkan dalam tabel ini. Jadi kalau bit-nya nol dan basis-nya z, dia akan
menyiapkan qubit dalam state nol. atau kalau bit-nya satu dan basis-nya X, dia akan menyiapkannya dalam state minus. Kalau
kamu tidak yakin apa basis dan state kuantum ini, tidak apa-apa. Poin utama yang perlu kamu ketahui adalah bahwa
pengukuran dalam setiap basis hanya memiliki dua kemungkinan hasil. 0 atau satu untuk basis-Z dan plus atau minus untuk basis X.
Kalau kamu mengukur state nol dalam basis-Z, kamu akan selalu mendapatkan nol.
Tapi kalau kamu mengukur state yang sama dalam basis-x, kamu akan mendapatkan hasil acak entah plus atau minus masing-masing dengan kemungkinan 50%.
Jadi Alice mungkin menyiapkan string qubit seperti ini di mana ini adalah string acak dari
nol dan satu dan ini adalah string acak dari x dan z. Jadi elemen pertama dalam masing-masing dari dua urutannya
adalah 0 dan x. Jadi itu berarti dia akan menyiapkan qubit pertama dalam state plus dan seterusnya.
Setelah dia menyiapkan semua state qubit-nya, Alice akan mengirimkan qubit-qubit ini kepada Bob dan Bob akan secara acak memilih antara X
dan Z sebagai basis di mana dia akan mengukur masing-masing. Jadi kita sekarang menambahkan beberapa baris ke
tabel untuk merepresentasikan pilihan dan pengukuran Bob. Jadi ini adalah pengukuran
dan pilihan basis Bob. Dan ini adalah hasil pengukurannya dari qubit yang dikirimkan Alice kepadanya. Akhirnya, Bob
bisa mengonversi setiap pengukuran ke bit menggunakan tabel yang sama yang digunakan Alice untuk menyiapkan qubit-nya. Ketika dia mengukur
state nol atau plus, dia menetapkan nilai bit nol. Dan di mana dia mengukur state satu atau minus, dia menempatkan
satu. Jadi string bit akhir Bob adalah baris terakhir ini.
Perhatikan bahwa ketika basis persiapan Alice dan basis pengukuran Bob cocok, maka bit-bit mereka juga akan cocok.
Tapi kalau Alice memilih menyiapkan Z dan Bob mengukur dalam X atau sebaliknya,
maka bit-bit yang sesuai dari Alice dan Bob tidak harus sama. Jadi, cara mereka berdua bisa menyepakati string bit
untuk one-time pad mereka adalah dengan saling menelepon dan memberi tahu basis mana yang mereka gunakan untuk setiap qubit.
Ketika basis cocok, mereka menyimpan bit tersebut dan ketika tidak cocok, mereka membuangnya.
Jadi, dalam kasus ini, Alice dan Bob keduanya akan menyepakati string bit 0 0 1 0
0. Bagaimana skema ini melindungi dari penyadap yang tidak terdeteksi? Nah, mari kita lihat apa yang terjadi ketika penyadap seperti itu
bernama Eve mencegat qubit yang dikirimkan Alice kepada Bob. Dia tidak tahu dalam state apa qubit-qubit ini berada atau bagaimana
Alice menyiapkan mereka. Jadi, berkat prinsip ketidakpastian dan sesuatu yang disebut teorema no-cloning, dia tidak bisa
begitu saja membuat salinan identik dari qubit untuk diteruskan kepada Bob. Kalau dia bisa, maka dia akan bisa
menyadap tanpa terdeteksi. Sebaliknya, dia menebak basis di mana dia akan mengukur setiap qubit, mengukurnya, dan kemudian
menyiapkan set qubit palsu baru untuk dikirimkan kepada Bob. Ada cara lain yang lebih licik yang bisa dicoba Eve untuk
mempelajari tentang qubit-qubit, tapi tidak ada yang bisa menghindari prinsip ketidakpastian.
Jadi, kita akan berasumsi menggunakan metode penyadapan Eve yang sederhana ini. Ini adalah tabel yang mendeskripsikan
persiapan Alice, penyadapan Eve, dan pengukuran akhir Bob. Jadi sekarang ketika
Alice dan Bob berbicara di telepon untuk membandingkan basis mereka, mereka akan memutuskan untuk menyimpan bit-bit ini untuk kunci mereka, tapi
bit-bitnya tidak cocok. Ini karena Bob mengukur qubit yang disiapkan Eve, bukan qubit asli yang dimiliki Alice.
Kalau mereka membandingkan subset dari bit dalam string bit mereka satu sama lain, mereka akan melihat bahwa beberapa tidak cocok dan
mengasumsikan bahwa pasti ada penyadap. Jadi karena Eve ditemukan, Alice dan Bob akan membuang
string bit mereka dan memulai protokol dari awal lagi. Tapi kalau Eve tidak mendengarkan dan subset dari
bit yang dibandingkan Alice dan Bob cocok, maka mereka bisa melanjutkan dan menggunakan bit yang tersisa yang tidak mereka
bandingkan sebagai kunci bersama mereka. Setelah Alice dan Bob memiliki kunci bersama, Alice bisa mengirimkan pesan terenkripsi kepada Bob, dan
Bob adalah satu-satunya yang bisa mendekripsinya menggunakan kunci tersebut. Sekarang setelah kita membahas protokolnya, mari kita coba di
komputer kuantum. Ada beberapa hal yang perlu diingat untuk eksperimen ini. Pertama,
BB84 benar-benar hanya berguna kalau Alice dan Bob berada jauh satu sama lain. Untuk eksperimen yang akan kita lakukan, Alice
dan Bob berada pada chip kuantum yang sama. Jadi, eksperimen ini tidak akan berguna untuk bertukar informasi pribadi, tapi ini
masih merupakan demonstrasi konseptual BB84 yang baik.
Kedua, komputer kuantum nyata memiliki noise. Jadi bahkan kalau basis persiapan Alice cocok dengan basis pengukuran Bob
dan tidak ada penyadap, masih ada kemungkinan kecil bahwa mereka akan mengukur bit yang berbeda karena kesalahan dalam
komputer kuantum. Ketika mereka membandingkan string bit mereka untuk memeriksa penyadap, mereka perlu memiliki toleransi terhadap kesalahan sebelum mereka
menyimpulkan bahwa penyadap pasti telah mengganggu mereka dan mereka membuang seluruh kunci. Sekarang dengan
catatan-catatan itu, mari kita mulai dengan eksperimen tanpa penyadap. Pertama, kita secara acak
menghasilkan tiga string bit yang berbeda, masing-masing dengan 20 bit. Yang pertama adalah string bit awal Alice.
Yang kedua adalah daftar basis di mana Alice akan menyiapkan qubit-nya.
Di sini kita sudah memilih nol untuk mewakili basis Z dan satu untuk mewakili basis X. Daftar terakhir adalah basis di mana
Bob akan mengukur setiap qubit. Berdasarkan tiga daftar tersebut, kita bisa membuat diagram circuit dengan instruksi untuk
persiapan Alice dan pengukuran Bob. Semua qubit dimulai dalam state nol. Jadi untuk menyiapkan qubit-nya dalam
basis Z, Alice entah tidak melakukan apa pun untuk state nol atau menerapkan NOT atau X gate yang ditampilkan sebagai kotak biru berlabel X
untuk state satu. Untuk menyiapkan dalam basis X, dia menerapkan Hadamard gate yang mengubah nol ke state plus
atau NOT gate diikuti Hadamard untuk menyiapkan state minus. Kemudian dia mengirimkan qubit-qubit kepada Bob. Set kotak berikutnya
dalam circuit merepresentasikan pengukuran Bob. Untuk mengukur dalam basis Z, dia tidak perlu menerapkan gate tambahan apa pun.
WEBVTT
Dia hanya mengukur, yang ditampilkan oleh kotak-kotak abu-abu ini. Untuk mengukur dalam basis X, dia pertama menerapkan Hadamard dan
kemudian dia mengukur. Kita akan menjalankan circuit ini menggunakan Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. Dan outputnya adalah string bit
pengukuran Bob. Kemudian kita bisa membandingkan string bit Bob dengan string bit awal Alice dengan membuang bit-bit
di mana basis mereka tidak cocok. Dan kita melihat bahwa keduanya mendapatkan kunci yang sama.
Ingat ini adalah hardware nyata jadi kadang-kadang mungkin ada bit yang seharusnya cocok tapi tidak. Dalam kasus ini semua
bit cocok tapi kalau kamu menjalankan ini lagi sendiri kamu bisa mendapatkan kesalahan tapi selama fidelitasnya mendekati satu
Alice dan Bob bisa cukup yakin bahwa tidak ada penyadap. Sekarang mari kita lihat apa yang terjadi kalau Eve mencegat
qubit-qubit tersebut. Sekarang kita punya dua circuit. Yang pertama menunjukkan persiapan Alice dan penyadapan serta pengukuran Eve.
Yang berikutnya menunjukkan persiapan Eve dari qubit palsu dan pengukuran Bob. Kita
bisa menjalankan circuit-circuit ini seperti sebelumnya, kemudian melihat apa yang akan didapat Alice dan Bob ketika mereka membandingkan string bit
mereka. Kali ini mereka mendapatkan fidelitas 0,6 berulang. Ini jauh lebih rendah dari
apa yang bisa dijelaskan oleh noise pada komputer kuantum. Jadi mereka menyimpulkan bahwa Eve sedang menyadap. Quantum computing
sudah terkenal dan sering dibesar-besarkan karena potensinya untuk menyelesaikan masalah yang sulit. Tapi komunikasi kuantum dan kriptografi
seringkali mendapat perhatian yang jauh lebih sedikit meskipun potensi yang bisa ditawarkan kuantum di area ini sama-sama
signifikan dan menarik. Hari ini kita membahas protokol yang paling awal ditemukan untuk quantum key distribution yang
praktis kebal terhadap penyadapan yang tidak terdeteksi. Kalau kamu ingin mencoba mengirimkan kode yang tidak bisa dipecahkan dengan
kunci bersertifikat kuantum, kunjungi modul yang ditautkan di deskripsi.
Terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali.